the Stars turned out for the 10th annual
glisten respect awards were there
opening up about why it's so important
to speak out against bullying and they
also shared their personal stories
you've been very open about your own
experiences with bullying as a child
tell me about that experience and also
how you overcame it um well you know I
had some neighbors who were pretty a few
much torment of my family you know it
wasn't great we end up having to move
because he got so bad but uh you know
for me it wasn't like I didn't feel like
I was one of those things like where I
overcame it was more when I when I got
older and I found dance I was like Jamie
like a purpose give me a focus and
motivation but looking back on it you
know I really just made me sort of think
about it like why people feel like they
have to do that to somebody and why you
know and now I'm not just pulling in
that what we think of as you know
physical abuse and you know now it's
social media now it's it's everywhere
it's just it's just constant negativity
really overcoming it was really the
realizing that when you love yourself
when you're totally full you know you
love you are you only gonna give love
and some people who Chuck hey interject
negativity especially through social
media are clearly seeking something that
you know they're there they're taking
theirs then there's nothing in there and
I don't mean that a negative way I just
me that they're not allowing themselves
to feel the goodness and they already
have inside themselves how does it feel
to have a platform like Dancing with the
Stars and just dance in general to be
able to tell these kinds of stories um
you know what I do it's wonderful it's
it's something I've never really thought
about you know I never liked thought oh
oh you know one day I'm going to tell
people about this or anything like that
it just sort of as was like a natural I
don't know progression and I just wanted
to share for me to share certain stories
in my life you know it seemed very
natural and and for me I just want to
like I want to be a servant I want to
like you know help and serve people and
and you know I want to be one be
forgiving you know i wanna i want to be
for giving to others